Myself Arun Pradeep from CSE department. I am currently pursuing
third year and I am working on one
of an hackathon project which is the
they will give a particular topic and the user need to talk about
the topic for two minutes. And the two minute transcript will be stored
in a particular file that I already mentioned where it need to be stored.
And once the file was stored in the form of MP3 format,
the MP3 format will be go
to that call by using an API known as Assembly Assembly
API which will use to give get the transcript of a particular MP3
file and once that file was completed,
which means the once the transcript was completed, the user
need to user can get
access to that recordings as well as
the transcript. So in that backend folder that I have created there
are two files. One file is the MP3 file
in which the audio recording of a user will
be stored and the other file the file consists of the transcript of the
file. And this is the base model for the prototype that I am working
for. And once the transcript was done and dusted,
by using an another API, maybe GPT
2.0 version, we can check
whether how the user spoke in a particular
region region, the sense how he spoke and in
which math in which area he need to concentrate more. So likewise we
can predict his moves. And this is
the whole idea about the particular project.